looks like you know your stuff how did
you know
she teaches all the money hacks that's
why i follow her
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i'm
george campbell ramsey personality
joined today by my friend dr john
deloney best-selling author ramsey
personality host of the dr john dolone
show and we are here to help today so
let us know what's on your mind what is
causing you anxiety there's not a lot
going on in the news john so i can't
imagine what could be freaking people
out these days
but i'm not here i'm not a geopolitical
expert i just talk about personal
finance and i want to keep it that way
yeah i can tell you though man that
stuff's been weighing on me waiting on
me heavy um i saw your post today i
follow you on facebook
you're the one i'm the one you're the
one um yeah i i i've
been replaying i've watched the
ukrainian people and
this astounding bravery
and
there's several videos floating around
of a father
um
you know hugging his daughter goodbye as
he puts her in a car she's a little
bitty girl and
i i mean i'm a father of a little girl
and a young son and i i can't help but
replay that in my own mind like what
would that feel like what would that be
doing and then i have to constantly
remind myself that thinking about that
what would you do in this situation
that's good it's good to do that
and yet today no one's called me to
fight and so if i stay there if i simply
loop and repeat and repeat and repeat
and repeat
i'm just gonna spend time not being
present in my community in my house in
my home and so man one of the greatest
antidotes and this is this is
neuroscience but one of the greatest
antidotes to that sort of rumination is
service getting out and doing something
from somebody else and so if there's
ever been a day
where you feel helpless like i do today
man and just just watching folks just
get slot i mean if you ever feel
helpless
today's the day go pick up somebody's
tab tonight at dinner right go over tip
your waiter or waitress so obnoxiously
so that you change the their whole month
right
um do something for somebody else and
that has a leavening effect on our
hearts and minds and it helps lift the
whole community up right now which is
what we need man absolutely good
reminders there john thanks for the
encouragement open phones this hour
triple eight eight two five five two two
five let's talk about your life your
money mental health boundaries
relationships all the stuff that's
ruminating in your mind let's talk about
it brian joins us kicking off this hour
in lakeland florida brian welcome to the
ramsay show
hi dr john hi george how are you both
doing we are doing great how can we help
today
yes uh so my wife and i are on baby step
four through six we paid off our
consumer debt recently and we were
blessed to receive a company bonus that
allowed us to essentially leapfrog
babysit three in less than a month
awesome uh yeah so because we have been
accustomed to being silica zone tense we
feel unified to proceed on to paying off
the house with the same intensity so
george is mainly for you as someone who
is paid off their house so quickly today
is my birthday and i'm wondering if you
have any tips advice or areas of
motivation you have for us to paid off
by hopefully my next birthday uh you got
me as a good dig brian george there's
somebody here i'm trying brian i'm
trying he's getting there
don't worry hey i'm gonna join the club
one day with georgetown make sure you
pre-order john's book to help him pay
off his house faster being in a club
with george is not something many of us
would ever aspire to but wow maybe this
club well thanks for that great intro
john well brian uh first of all
congratulations i think it's awesome
that you guys have this really cool goal
and happy birthday what a way to spend
it then with two of your best friends
john and george appreciate it thank you
so
here's what i'll tell you
everyone's situation looks different
when it comes to baby steps four five
six
there's there's no wrong way to do it
the only wrong way to do it is to have
no intentionality and no goals and just
float and hope and so what i want you to
do is set a goal and you're saying you
want to pay this house off in 365 days
is that correct
that's correct is that feasibly possible
based on your income and how much is
left on the mortgage
well and that's one thing i'm curious
about if we should continue being as
david says gazelle intense because our
main jobs bring in 120 and with our side
hustles if we continue to proceed on
with that we can bring in 155 and we
have 77 luck on the house oh well this
is yeah the numbers here are very
promising i think it's a really cool
goal i mean i'll i'll tell you this if
you can still enjoy your life to some
degree and not look back with regret and
go oh my gosh
we didn't go on that vacation and we
should have we didn't do this and we
should have we should have upgraded the
car because it was running on fumes and
we should have i would still plan for
some of that stuff to happen and that
way you don't feel guilty on either side
and i'll tell you my general rule of
thumb is 12 to 18 months
if you can have 12 to 18 months of
lunacy and have something done forever
um
then i say go i mean to me george it'd
be worth a vacation and be worth it
whatever to knock that out if you look
up and say okay it's going to take us 36
months there's a reason why baby steps
four five and six we tell people
man you gotta breathe too right if you
sprint forever your body will shut you
down if you think you can grind this
sucker out in 12 months i see i mean you
already see the light at the end of the
tunnel this is not a hey this is a six
year journey should we be intense uh we
talk about this we say you know gazelle
intensity is great but once you get to
six we go from intense to intentional
and that's exactly what you're doing by
saying we're gonna be really intentional
we're gonna pay this thing off in 12
months and then we get to be in baby
step seven living and giving like no one
else man and you can taste it i mean you
guys are really really close you have a
great income and if the side hustles
aren't crushing your life i'm going to
tell you to keep doing it if that's your
goal there's nothing wrong with that hey
brian you you know what i would love to
see you and your wife do i'd love to see
y'all put a big star next to something
you're going to do and this when this
year is over
like what is your birthday celebration
going to be next year or what is a month
after your birthday so
put a big carrot out there dangle it in
front of you and then that will give you
some some some coal in in the engine
here as you go down the track that will
make sure you go all the way through
that that year but it's not going to
you're not going to be missing out on
everything it's not going to feel all
all overwhelming right yeah you can get
there how does that feel brian
no that feels great yeah
the one thing i'm just curious about
because i know what with baby stuff too
most of these things were charging you
interest by the day and so now that
we're dealing with the mortgage where
regardless of what payment you do
they're going to charge you in just by
the month so that's one kind of cures of
how to continue grinding when you're not
really necessarily necessarily needing
to make a payment until the next month
so um
here's a thing that i learned when i was
running track
sometimes you race um
in a race like in a race race you're
racing your compadres right you're
racing the people on the track who's
next to you your your competitors fellow
competitors
but most of the time when you're
grinding out your training you're racing
yourself you're racing a watch
and so who cares at this point you are
so close to the finish line here who
cares what the interest rate is you've
got a fixed number that you're going
after that you're going to whittle away
at i i would i would not even let that
enter my mind you have no other
competitors from this point forward but
you
and you're racing the watch here on this
one let's just knock it out man who
cares about that stuff
thank you both i appreciate it yeah man
thanks so much for getting it man man i
love to hear stuff like that i mean he
sounds like a young guy real intentional
and it's possible because they just got
real focused they have the shovel
they're doing the side hustles and
they're willing to stick it out and
they're they're they're being they're
being extra they're being even more
counter-cultural than we usually tell
folks to do and they're saying you know
what one more year we're gonna bite the
bullet on this one and then on my
birthday next year the gift i want is to
owe nobody anything i love it brian call
us back when you pay off that mortgage
on your next birthday can't wait for
that call hey stick around coming up we
are going to be playing a video from
tick tock and we will react to it and
who knows what john's reaction will be
he's never he doesn't know what to talk
about it's gonna be good stick around
triple eight eight two five five two two
five you call us we'll talk about your
life and your money this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest-serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
deloney
all right john
you know about tick tock
[Music]
uh i've got several of them on the wall
in my house oh boy okay this is going to
take a while guys buckling so tick-tock
is a social media platform i know what
it is it's blown up in popularity among
the youth and now among the olds yeah
that's what they call it they call them
the old the olds yes
i'm learning from gen z i'm learning and
so here's the deal this radio show is
mostly geared towards the olds if you've
heard about tick tock you know oh isn't
that just like weird dance challenges it
has become so much more and so there's a
lot of personal finance tick talkers out
there creating content to help the
people yeah i've seen the uh some of the
uh personal physical fitness and mental
health advice
that uh shows up on your feed some of
the tick talkers are bestowing upon us
all yeah and it's a it's a lot of 17
year olds with opinions about how you
should handle your money
talks and i know everything you're a
genius i'm a genius so i i stumble upon
videos all the time that just cause me
to be very angry very instantly because
it's just a cesspool of terrible
financial advice
that is
just helping gen z go into debt faster
ah because that's how to set up the
youth of america for their adult life
thanks tiktok and so as i come across
them i thought why don't we play one on
the show for all of america to hear okay
let me set this up this is a girl who's
playing two characters same person two
characters it's going back and forth and
it's she's the mom and she's the
daughter but talking to herself in a
very clever way yes i know i love
cleveland the mom is anti-credit card
and the daughter is explaining to mom
why she's a why she's a genius and you
should have a credit card so let's play
the clip and let's see your reaction
i'm ready for my first credit card
absolutely not credit cards are evil
honey no they're not do you even know
how they work yeah it's literally a card
with money on it the money belongs to a
bank and every time i use the card to
buy something i'm borrowing their money
to pay for it see you're using their
money this is going to get you into a
lot of debt no it can get me into debt
if i use it irresponsibly but i won't
let that happen how are you going to
manage that when the bill comes each
month i have the option to pay the
minimum amount or the entire amount that
i borrowed if i pay the full amount
every month then i'll never owe any
interest or get into debt and what if
you forget to pay i won't spend more
money than i have and i'll turn on
autopay so it will automatically pay off
the entire balance every month fine but
why not just use your debit card if you
have the money anyways they reward you
with things like cash back or free
travel plus it builds your credit score
okay it looks like you know your stuff
how did you learn all this addison
taught me she teaches all the money
hacks that's why i literally want to set
my own hair on fire john
i can't breathe just just to see if i
can still feel
what is way to go america i think i held
my breath during that whole video i'm
just now realizing yeah you should
breathe during times of stress you have
experience with breathing exercises that
is right so okay there's a lot to unpack
here john um
there's like there's very little to
unpack
you're right but i just need to say it
because it needs to be said
that advice
is one of the many reasons and let me
tell you that video millions of views
really half a million likes wow
this is what the younger generations are
clinging to going yes finally someone
who gets it because my mom was just
telling me the same thing dumb i'm like
mom you don't understand i'm gonna pay
it off every month
and so it just brings me to this point
will smith already sing that song
parents just don't understand we've
we've dealt with the credit card issue
time and time again but let me just
reiterate why
that advice is going to cause a lot of
harm to your life number one
we get a lot of debt-free screams that
come through this lobby we've had 72 so
far this year that have paid off over 10
and a half million dollars total
you know how they went into that debt
john do you think they went and opened a
credit card and said well i'm going to
pay it off every month so why everyone
who opens the credit cards like i'll
take care of it no one opens one going
oh can't wait to go into debt and carry
a balance every month you know what i
really want to do
shackle my family in all of our future
dreams that sounds awesome it's a good
time that's right and here's the thing
in a perfect world where there was no
sin there was no fall of man we could
probably use credit cards responsibly
john james george is getting existential
we live in a fallen world and humans are
fallible creatures and we have the best
intentions don't we john i'm gonna work
out three times this week i actually did
but it's cool i forgot the bachelor was
on so i gotta miss this workout right
i'm just saying there's so many great
intentions we have as a society and then
what happens life hits us right
i thought i could make the payment and
then i couldn't and then this happened
and this happened so i had to get a
personal loan and so then i had to get
the car loan and it's just right to
borrow from my roommate and then all of
a sudden my friendship's kind of wonky
right this exact thing that exact advice
when i was in college i had a credit
card and actually i i would pay it off
every month paid off every month paid
off every month and then my transmission
fell out of my
88 tercel easy hatchback right and
big shocker right
and i didn't have it that month and so i
was like i'll make it up i'll make it up
years went by before i made it up right
and it took one thing that happened one
thing that caught me all right let me
hit you with some stats in the face i
prefer you don't hit me but
i i couldn't if i wanted to americans
total credit card balance today stands
at 856 billion dollars with a b
every single one of those people said
i'm going to pay it off every month
let me hit you another one national
average card debt among card holders
with unpaid balances over 6 500
americans carried a balance on 52 of all
active credit card accounts in the third
quarter of 2021. so they're just handing
money over to
massive banking institutions so one out
of two people who had great intentions
are carrying a balance and a large one
at that and for all credit cards here's
the average apr the interest rate on
these things is almost 16
right now oh my gosh and so here's the
thing she's saying well i can get two
percent
or you could pay 16
on that money
which counteracts every little bit of
every penny that you got towards your
flight points which by the way who knows
what 200 000
points are worth they do that on purpose
so that it's confusing and you think
you're rich and then you go try to book
a flight and i go sorry you need a
hundred thousand more points
you can buy those for another 400 though
and so on top of that there's the credit
score argument you got to build your
score
right john to eat to breathe to to get
married you got to have that credit
score to be a respectable american adult
you better have a good credit score
right
and as someone who didn't have a credit
score for a long time i just paid off my
mortgage it will fall away soon after i
got a mortgage without a credit score
i've rented cars without a credit score
i've rented apartments multiple without
a credit score houses without a credit
score and so this idea that we've
convinced our children that you need to
get a credit card early to build your
credit score to go into debt so you can
build a score to go into more debt is
the reason we are almost a trillion
dollars in credit card debt just just
credit card debt not just
mortgage debt car debt student loan debt
it was it was two big shockers one is
our friend anthony o'neil when he went
called up all of those apartment
complexes and just said hey i have no uh
no credit score can i still run an
apartment they're like yeah of course
you can 10 of them 10 out of 10 right
and then the other one was
if you got a million dollars tomorrow
your credit score would stay at zero
it has no
no relations to how much wealth you have
to how you handle money it's not money
management it's debt debt management
that's right so on top of that if there
wasn't enough john here's the thing if
you pay off your credit card every month
and you're a good little boy or good
little girl
you end up with zero dollars oh
right that's not a cash flow plan that
works no they give you uh two percent
cash back that's right i'm gonna get
rich and i've done the math on that john
in our fine print episode you know i
like to do math we did one on the true
cost of credit card rewards and i did
the math on here's what it would take
you would have to spend 25 30 000 to get
a few hundred dollars back
i hope it sounds so good when it says
cash back
that you're spending buying things you
already would have bought right that's
always the argument i'm only buying
things that i budgeted for right and we
know that the psychology of that debt is
not true you spend more money when
you're using plastic you spend more
money when you're clicking on when it's
someone else's internet that's exactly
right when i'm exchanging cash yeah so
there's a lot going on here on top of
all of you hit me baby one more time on
top of all that john here's the part
that people don't think about when you
get the cash back
it's usually on the backs of the people
who couldn't afford it
that's the one that haunts me as a
citizen as a neighbor
that
i get my lower rate because somebody
else is struggling to pay their lives
someone else got screwed that's exactly
right how do you like your flight now
and i'm participating in a system that's
hurting people
enjoy your free vacation guys
wow all right stay off of tick tock for
now john firstly forever maybe forever
we'll get on there john we'll we'll
change the world forever one tick tock
at
dances
good stuff this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
you are listening to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by ramsay
personality dr john deloney and on the
debt-free stage we have james and
lindsay how are you guys what's up good
you too where you guys from
michigan michigan i'll take it yes okay
and here to do your debt-free scream you
made it from the cold to the cold and we
are here for it we brought snow to our
warm city this morning so thank you for
that
fantastic so how much debt have you guys
paid off 450 000.
okay
that had an extra zero than i was
expecting
that's incredible and how long did that
take
uh nine years
okay and what was the range of income
during that time uh 90 to 120. wow
a nine year journey sprinting for a
decade
i feel like there's there's a story in
here somewhere what do you guys do for a
living
uh i do um bookkeeping accounting cool
financial and i'm a plumber pipefitter
and owned a business for the past four
years fantastic
awesome awesome okay so what type of
debt was the 450
well you know in the beginning we had a
little credit card and you know not much
in that and then we had a vehicle and
you know the the usual stuff and uh
house you know you paid your house
yeah no more mortgages we're looking at
weird people john
yeah dude your house what's it worth
well we actually sold it and we're on
the road right now we're going to build
up in northern michigan completely
debt-free wow
you're just hoofing it now
you're rving it
living the youtube dreams man that's
incredible guys way to go you guys are
incredible okay
nine years is a long time to stay
focused on any goal how did you guys do
this and what got you started
family friends church you know i mean we
heard it from a few different uh avenues
i guess if you will
and uh you know we just i'm like man
paid off house that's that's unheard of
and
we said we want that you know so yeah we
uh we want what's after that the peace
yes after that and the ability to bless
others because
so who sat down and had the first
conversation with who and said i'm tired
of living like this let's do something
different
that conversation didn't go well did it
well it it did and it didn't but you
know i mean most of the the beginning
debt was mine so it wasn't you know it
wasn't that hard so um
you know we just
yeah got after it so how much of this
debt was the house
uh well we had about
about
uh 350. wow so you had 100 on the
consumer debt side and you got through
all of that and just kept plowing
through and actually to clarify we were
down 45 more that was the first house so
we we almost we almost paid off the
first house paid off the second house
wow wow very cool so how do you stick it
out for nine years because there's some
people out there who have been doing
this plan for nine months and they're
going it's just been too long i don't
know if i can stick it out
end game you know i mean
that that light at the end of the tunnel
and
you know we just it wasn't that we did
it nine straight years i think we like i
think everybody has ups and downs sure
and we had those too some months you
were crushing it and some you're like
man this is hard
so what was the hardest part over the
nine years
what was the hardest thing you guys had
to do it
boy i don't i mean really just you know
i mean the budget's obviously hard you
know i mean
yeah
wow did you guys live your life along
the way or was it just like nothing yeah
i mean we were yeah no problem
look at james he's like oh brother i'm
living
we lived hey so um you've got two little
kids what yeah what
what what got in your mind and your
hearts and souls to make this transition
to sell your house and road trip it for
a while well we
liked the area we were in but we uh you
know we wanted to be a little further
north uh where it's colder for some
reason but uh yeah be a little further
north and and there's you know we love
boating and there's a lot of stuff to do
up there and these girls love that the
outdoors you know
i guess the outdoors drew us north
and to do this and to you know
continue the journey so how many more
years do you get left um on on the road
oh we're just a couple months we're
gonna we're gonna head yeah
we've been on the road for almost two
months and then we'll head back here
maybe two weeks
when the snow goes down you'll start
building your new house then yes wow so
you're ready to rock and roll in this
new place yep wow that's incredible you
guys are awesome we're so proud of you
thank you so tell people who are maybe
just starting this journey who have
aspirations to have a paid for home like
you guys what do you tell people the key
to getting out of debt is
being consistent
and knowing that you're doing it if you
have children it's for your kids um it's
for
what you can do when you're debt-free um
the people that you can bless along the
way now i mean even in the four months
that we've been debt-free what we've
experienced the testimonies from
god has been incredible
what do you tell folks who are
fantasizing they watch one too many hgtv
shows or youtube clips and they think
i'm gonna sell everything and hit an rv
and we're gonna take the family on the
road what's one thing you'd pass along
to them
do it
for sure
get after it yeah it's worth it i can
tell on your faces there's a levity and
joy that can only come from that level
of financial peace okay so if you had
the moment you've been debt-free for a
few months have you had the moment where
i'm assuming you've had the moment where
the paycheck deposits
and you don't have any bills and you
just get to keep all of your own money
yeah all of it and then you get to tip
that waitress really really well yes
that's incredible yeah dude i i wish if
you're not if you're just listening to
this you can't see go on youtube and
watch youtube guys are glowing like
lamps man you're just you're smiling i
can feel it through the glass it's
incredible man
the piece is written all over you and
having those whys is so important you've
got the kids you've got wanting to give
more and the freedom and options that
come with this when you don't have a
payment in the world including to your
mortgage lender it's a game changer you
guys are amazing so you brought the
kiddos with you we've been talking about
them bring them up what are their names
and ages
adeline is 10 and hayden will be
five tomorrow oh happy birthday happy
early birthday tomorrow
happy birthday what a beautiful family
and it's even more beautiful when
they're dead free john there's just a
glow about them i think they're always
beautiful okay that's fair but that's
fair well we have got a copy of dave's
national bestselling book baby steps
millionaires that is absolutely the next
chapter in your journey as you've
changed your family tree as you leave
this amazing legacy for your family
we're so proud of you and we're gonna
give you a copy of dave's book the total
money makeover that's helped so many
people get on this plan and so i hope
you give it to that person maybe you put
a hundred dollar bill in there along
with it as a little bribe say hey read
this it changed our life and happy
birthday hayden that's right happy happy
birthday i thought you were going to
start singing john i went don't do that
i almost did but we're going to the time
for a thousand reasons don't do it
all right you guys ready you've been
practicing in the car yeah you're ready
you ready okay here we go we've got
james and lindsey and adalyn and hayden
450 000 paid off house and everything in
nine years making 90 to 120 count it
down let's hear a debt free scream three
two one we're debt free
[Applause]
awesome
and the party continues with a birthday
tomorrow happy birthday not to me not to
you man
that stuff never gets old john
it's it's it's watching people i i love
watching people's body posture um that's
a that's i love watching people as they
explain how what freedom
sounds like it feels like but i like
watching their body because you can
watch them over the arc of uh jeffrey's
scream they talk about hey here's what
happened and they their bodies low and
you can hear it in their voice you see
on their face and as they start
processing out loud i don't have any
payments i don't owe anybody anything
you it's like a light comes on man and
these two are just glowing the whole
family is so beautiful it's glowing like
crazy i just love it i love it love it
love it it's like one of those frames at
walmart of just the perfect family
that's them right now just pure joy and
they're not actors this is real life
that's the difference they're not paid
actors man we're so proud of you guys
this is what we do we do this for this
reason john that's right i love seeing
this impact yeah and um if you are
watching this on youtube and you can see
james if you ever wondered what i look
like in a t-shirt we pretty much have
the same upper body yeah he works out
just a little more hey uh i'm gonna
agree with you on that i think he's our
point pretty sure that he does wow
better impulse control too i want the
listeners to know that they may list be
listening going that can't be me i'm not
james and lindsay i've done too many
stupid things i got too much debt man
there is still hope for you it's never
too late i don't care if you're 20 or
you're 80. you can get out of debt you
can experience the same freedom and you
made it you're radical for four months
yep or nine years worth it worth it
worth it it's worth it every time this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell ramsey personality
joined today by dr john deloney and we
are taking your calls about life money
relationships career mental health
wellness the metaverse we'll talk about
it all
eight eight two five five two two five
is the number to call our question of
the day comes from blinds.com find out
for yourself why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping and with the new promos
they run every month you'll save even
more make sure to use the promo code
ramsey to get the best deal today's
question comes from taylor in maryland
taylor writes i'm married to a serious
spin thrift
i started using every dollar when he was
incarcerated three years ago well i'll
go ahead and underline that one
and with my single income i was able to
tithe pay all our bills on time fund car
and home repairs and pay off 40 000 in
student loan debt with 65 000 left to go
can i just stop there
incredible taylor way to go
in our phone conversations he makes big
future money plans that i think are
unwise
if we benefit from the navient
settlement where the debt is canceled
and refunds are paid out the timing of
the payout would be just after he'll
return home how do i deal with the
stress of trying to keep any refund from
being wasted
he's seen the success from following the
plan and his response is basically
that's great i'm proud of you but we're
not following that plan when i get home
there's a lot of yikes going on in this
situation john but man taylor's
incredible taylor just solo her out i'm
like man she's crushing it it's it's
it's it does my heart good when we can
just stop and stop the the party here
for a second and just call somebody out
and say what an incredible human being
while your husband was in jail for a
couple of three years
you managed to take control back in your
home and i guarantee you took control
back in your heart and your mind your
spirit and you started just saying how
can i move forward and instead of
curling up you went after me this is
incredible
this is an inspiring person
so he george here's a a a problem i i
see that haunts all of us okay not just
taylor haunts all of us
and i'll um
i'll use this as an example
when my son was born he was a day old
and we brought him our two day three
days we brought him home from the
hospital
i could see the chaos that erupted into
our home i didn't know we had to change
diapers i knew it changed diapers i
didn't know it was 10 times a day and i
didn't know this and all that and
suddenly this clock started ticking in
my head which was when things get back
to normal
when
when things are just gonna get back to
the way they were when me and my wife
could just go on dates whenever we
wanted to we could spend money like
idiots we could do whatever we wanted to
do
when they just gets back to normal right
and
whether it's having a new baby whether
it's dating and then getting married
whether it's getting a new job moving to
a new town or whether it's your
husband's coming home from three years
it's so easy to just
default to well when things get back to
the way they were
and unfortunately and fortunately there
is no going back right things are
different now and so i love love this
analogy
that you could not go to manhattan and
get all of the glass and steel and smoke
and dust
and sweep it all up and rebuild the twin
towers you can't do that you we had to
go in with architects and construction
firms and demo teams and excavate the
whole site get some professionals around
us and say what's this new building
going to look like
and we get to redesign it it gets to be
strong it gets to be arguably beautiful
it gets to be a monument to what was and
a nod to the future and we're going to
rebuild something completely different
so when i look at somebody like this
like taylor who has had to be on their
own because for whatever reason her
husband was in jail for three years
there is no going back
there's taylor's world now right and
taylor has sounds like she's found a new
voice she's found some actions that back
up that voice and she's
found two feet planted in the ground and
what i want taylor to do is to
immediately go sit with a counselor
that's going to help with re-entry here
how are you going to
learn how to speak your boundaries out
loud how are you going to say
i'm sorry but this is like we're going
to do this together now you're not just
going to come home and start making up
the rules that got you in trouble in the
first place right oh yeah and it's about
we're going to excavate what was we used
to run the house this way you used to do
some things this way
we're now going to do things different
or and then you gotta have your or what
statement right and so if somebody comes
home out of jail and immediately throws
my family back into a situation we're
not safe we're gonna have some hard
conversations right um yeah that i just
kept thinking taylor's a different
person now that's why she was three she
started the plan after he went to jail
right and now here she is a different
person with a different set of plans and
values and goals and different financial
standing and different strengths yeah
right different grit and resilience and
autonomy those these these deeply
embedded character things her body went
from fight or flight to
we're moving forward right and that's a
different that's a different physiology
i just kept thinking taylor's better off
alone than she is with him that was my
honest thought for you want to know john
well when it comes to money possibly and
it sounds like um i i i we you know we
always read into these things uh it
sounds like she
is hesitant about him coming home yeah
and so
man i want you to get with somebody
that's going to help turn these
boundaries these newfound
actions this newfound character you
found strength that's going to be able
to turn that into something that you can
share with somebody and that you can
stand up and say no no no this is my
boundaries from this point forward yeah
counseling is a non-negotiable here for
sure awesome thanks for the question
appreciate it all right kevin joins us
in baltimore maryland kevin welcome to
the ramsay show hey guys how's it going
great how can we help
just a quick back story on me i started
the baby steps i was turned on uh from a
guy that i work with to the baby steps
into the ramsey plan i started last year
was actually my new year's resolution
last year to start and actually see it
through and so far i've done that way to
go man awesome i'm uh i'm about seven
thousand dollars away from being done
baby step two um
that's on one of those stupid credit
cards that you guys were just talking
about a little while ago you had every
intention of paying off make a tick tock
video make a tick tock video man well
well my goal is to have it done by the
summer uh and by my birthday actually in
the summer so as of right now i don't
see any reason why i won't have it done
i love it um but looking forward i've
been listening to a lot of the podcast
and every once in a while somebody will
ask questions about uh real estate
investing uh rentals that type of thing
and i was curious if you guys or brand
solutions had uh some sort of literature
or some sort of like program
sort of like what you guys do with fpu
that
is kind of like a
at least a would be a good head start
for me
because like i said once i get to that
point i want to start preparing now so
that way when i get to that point um i
can potentially start investing in real
estate and
would like to hit the ground running as
opposed to hit the ground and fall on my
face yeah i was just curious if you guys
had anything or what should i be doing
now i guess to start planning for that
we do have some great resources you know
blog articles you can go through the
legacy journey if you're if you've got a
ramsey plus membership we've got that
whole course which is dave's plan for
kind of you've made it through the baby
steps now what and that's where real
estate investing would fall into so do
you currently have a a primary residence
and a mortgage
yeah so um unfortunately i
was in the process of building a house
when i got actually turned on to the
baby steps
so that part right now i'm kind of stuck
on until at least when i'm done through
baby step three and then i'm going to
reevaluate my mortgage and look into
potentially
uh you know
refinancing it maybe into a 15 year i've
heard him say about the um
you know to make sure that it's worth it
kind of like your break even type thing
so once i get done through baby step
three i'm gonna be i'm gonna visit that
and see where i am in regards to that
why are you waiting till baby step
three like what keeps you from going to
check on that right now
well the only reason i'm waiting right
now is because with only a few months
potentially left i'd like to have the
extra money to be able to knock out my
credit card debt as opposed to
the potentially higher mortgage that i'm
going to have every month you know a few
extra 100 that i might be able to put on
my debt as opposed to sending into the
mortgage okay well kevin i'll make it
real simple for you you're not ready to
be a real estate investor you've got to
make it through the baby steps which
means you get the fully funded emergency
fund we start investing 15 of our
household income to retirement if you've
got kids we're putting some money away
for college then we're paying off our
primary mortgage and then we're at baby
step seven and that is when you'd start
socking away cash and paying cash for
any other real estate as an investment
so george the question the answer to
this question ultimately is make a lot
of cash yes right start start socking
away and earning cash as fast follow the
plan pay everything off and you get to
keep all that rental income boom how's
that for roi thanks for the question
kevin that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600-plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your money your career
your relationships we do it all right in
front of you i'm joined today by dr john
dolone i'm george campbell ramsey
personality and we're here to help so
give us a call triple eight eight two
five five two two five we'll talk about
whatever you want to talk about
angela kicks off this hour she's in
cleveland ohio angela welcome to the
ramsay show
well hi thank you so much for taking my
call absolutely so
i guess um i really just needed a little
bit of direction here for um some plans
that i had for myself that were stalled
um actually nearing retirement age
getting there anyway
and
was
recently married in the middle of covid
eloped and we both are remarried now
and
i had had plans to relocate south out of
ohio
and then had a few
you know bad luck situations
had broken my back in a slip and fall
and my wrists so kind of laid what i was
doing for a living as an lpn
um but yet it also gave me the
opportunity to be there when my brother
passed away and things like that
so a lot of good came out of some bad
things and i stuck around in ohio
and met my husband so all good
now except you're in ohio i'm just
kidding yes that's the only missing part
oh yeah so um you know i'm at the point
now where i'm doing telephonic health
care and so i do have the ability to
relocate and my husband he um
he opened a business right before covet
and was just establishing and doing
great
um and then covered almost destroyed the
business
so we had you know a few steps forward
quite a few steps back but i guess what
i'm getting at is um
if you think it's a good idea to still
relocate um the house would sell we'd
use the proceeds and contingent on the
sale of the house purchase something
down south
and
might be more of a mortgage with the way
everything has just increased so much
but overall with much less property tax
i think we would still be at the same
house payment
so it's pretty much the same financial
situation just shifting it to a warmer
state
and then he would let his business go
and find something else to do
now he's 62 just turned 62 the other day
and i'm 60. so this is where we're at
we are on baby step well we don't have
kids in college we already
did the parts that we were doing there
um so we have no debt
we have six months in the bank we've got
vehicles paid off
and it's really just the money in the
house
and
shift that to a different home and
what's your what's your crash what's
your hesitancy
what's what's the why haven't you packed
up and moved yet there's something
hanging around
you know he he had a lease for his
business that will be up this summer so
we're
that's the only thing we were waiting
for does he want to be locked into that
oh yes he would love to so we both want
to
but something's holding you back what is
it besides the least something
existential um
oh gosh we have our kids up here but you
know oh dumb old kids come on in
grandchildren i think cloven has taught
us all that you can do this long
distance you really can't face pain is a
god's name for grandparents anymore when
did your brother pass away
uh i'm sorry when did your brother pass
away
oh it's been uh
six years now oh six years
yeah and then my dad too um so
kind of went from one health situation
where i was able to be there for him and
uh right into my dad
if i was the person and so now i kind of
feel like it's my turn yeah i
so i
i define grief this way grief is the gap
between
what i hoped for
or what i wanted to happen
and what really happened
there's that space
and i wanted my brother to live forever
and he didn't i wanted my dad to be
there forever and he wasn't i wanted my
job to fill in the blank whatever that
thing is i wanted to have a body look
like this and now i look in the mirror
and it looks like that right
grief is that
gap and anytime we try to jump over that
gap
and not walk through it
our body spends time and energy trying
to solve that gap
and so
here's my only concern
i want you to move the fact that you're
hesitating
makes me first think is there something
you are walking away from that you still
need to deal with because here's the
ugly part about moving you go with you
right oh that's correct no i did not
have a remote position
um until just the last 10 months so now
i'm lined up well i could still work
from home and work anywhere okay whether
we decided you know to i mean even if we
wanted to rent for a few months in one
town yeah i'm so i'm not talking about
money angela i'm talking about can you
leave ohio in in peace
can you i think i could okay i think
that's good that's the question then all
of the big things the big you know
legalities all of that loosens
all of that's over and done with
and now his is finishing up
okay so so i'm gonna pass it over to
george to talk money but listen to me
very carefully okay yes sir you're
talking about legalities you're talking
about leases you're talking about
i got a my job lined up all that stuff's
important and good that's all critical
to just moving halfway across i mean not
halfway all the way across the country
right what i'm talking about is the
spiritual nag that you feel
that's tugging on you
that you can leave ohio in peace that
you have grieved your brother and your
dad and i wanted this stuff to happen
because the way you describe your story
is i wanted all this stuff to happen and
it didn't and now i'm kind of here and
now i'm this this and what and i want
that stuff i want you to have
written about that i want you to have
processed that sat with a friend and
said you know what i've never said this
out loud because i'm always
i'm somebody who wants everybody to be
positive around me
like my heart was broken
or that sucked
when i broke my back
i would have been the chief this by i
want you to say those out loud and
that's not whining or complaining that's
processing very different things right
right no i went through that i did i
really did good
if the money works and i'll turn over
george i say run to florida with i yeah
you all need to be the kind one of y'all
needs to stand up in uh out the
sun roof of your car screaming and
yelling all the way to florida yeah
angela i mean you don't need our
permission to move but here's what i
would do i'd go get breakfast or a nice
dinner with your husband and
share all of your fears out loud about
moving and then start dreaming about
what your new life is going to look like
and then start making plans
we're going to do it there we go i think
i just needed to hear somebody else say
just go do it that's what we're here for
yeah and make sure like you say make
sure you got a job make sure you can
afford
payments on stuff make sure you like you
said the leases are done you're not
skipping out on town in the middle of
the night but yeah get to florida and
enjoy your years you've been taking care
of people for a long long time and
you've got a great career that's going
to allow you and your new husband to
just enjoy
life for a season excited for your move
angela go get a tan on your back you
deserve it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsay right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
dalon
well folks tax season is upon us i know
try to contain your excitement settle
down no one likes doing their taxes
especially when you realize what the big
software companies are up to every year
these companies lure you in by saying
you can file your taxes for free
then when you're knee-deep in the filing
process hours and they sucker punch you
with up charges loan offers and credit
card pitches you've sucker punched me
you've been there no one likes that
sucker punched yeah i got good news john
there's a better way there's a better
way it's called ramsey smart tax this is
our online tax filing software and with
ramsey smart tax you get all the
deductions all the forms every tax break
you deserve and the best part is the
price ours is already much lower than
the leading competitor and you won't
find any hidden fees plus this year we
have a promo code that will truly make
it free to file your federal taxes just
go to ramseysolutions.com
smart tax to get your promo code and
file without surprises that's ramsey
solutions dot com slash smart type
important note i did my taxes already
with ramsey smart tax if i'm going to be
selling the product i want to make sure
i'm using it
awesome and you sent me a text and it
was a picture of the website to log in
and it's my facebook i sat down with all
my text
reports and i moved some accounts this
year i had a bajillion it took it it had
a lot of stuff and i sit down
it's a late night the kids are in bed
i'm going to do it at night and then the
first thing i see is george's face
smiling face haunting you on the smart
tax talking to me doing my taxes yeah i
apologize to many americans who had to
experience the same fate burned off my
rods and cones man i was trying to
encourage you with a smile and go you
can do this that's what i needed it's
gonna be okay at nine o'clock at night
in the dark it's over now john texas
until next year until next year all
right seth joins us it's a free call
folks triple a two five five two two
five and seth is joining us in memphis
tennessee seth welcome to the ramsey
show
yes sir uh how are y'all great good
what's up brother speak speak directly
into your phone nice and loud for me
all right yes sir um so my wife and i
are debt-free and the baby steps four
five and six and my question has to do
with life insurance and how to
eventually become self-insured my wife
and i both we have 20-year
term life that's about 10 times our
income so we're following the plan
but this one when it gets to that point
when the 20 years is up it will be
roughly 48 to 50 years old and if all of
our investments are in
401ks and
iras
how do you have access to that money to
be self-insured
because if you're following the plan i
know at the end of 20 years you should
have your home paid off and the nest
eggs going so
uh just wondering about that um there's
probably something i'm missing or at
that point you just get another
shorter 10 or 15 years until you have
access to
your retirement account that's a great
question seth and you've nailed it i
mean that's that's what it means to be
self-insured and if you follow our plan
this is why we say that let's say you
have your 20-year term in place which is
great you've got the 15-year fixed-rate
mortgage which means the mortgage is
going to be paid off you've now been
investing 15
over those 20 years which means you are
a baby steps millionaire which means if
something happened to you god forbid
your wife's gonna be okay you've got a
paid for house you've got a whole bunch
of money sitting there in these
investment accounts and your question
was how do i access that money and the
thing is if you passed away
you would have what's called an
inherited ira go to your wife or
inherited 401k and she would be able to
use those funds so it kind of is i guess
a loop it's a sad loophole but if
someone dies it that there's a different
kind of treatment on that money that's
in the investment accounts yeah not so
much as a it's
it's just passing along i don't know if
it's a loophole it's just you have
access to this retirement account
because the retirement funds are not
going to be used for retirement so just
make sure that they're the beneficiary
your wife is the beneficiary on those
accounts so that if something did happen
it would go right to her and she would
be able to use those funds and so what
we talk about with being self-insured is
if you had a million dollars could she
live forever well what we're going to
say is we want to invest that money so
she could peel away a percentage of that
money and be able to live without
depleting all of it
but let's answer your other question too
let's say you get to 45
or 48 and something a couple of things
have happened along the way and you're
not where you need to be
then yeah i'd buy another 10-year policy
or a 15-year policy that will push you
maybe to 60 to 65 that will get you that
will be a bridge policy i wouldn't see a
problem with that at all yeah you can
always add more life insurance and you
can do it while you're young and if you
say let's say your income goes up right
you can add another chunk of life
insurance policy to make sure that you
have that 10 to 12 times your income
does that help success
absolutely thanks guys
there was something i was missing there
so that sounds good that's a great
question man i love it awesome question
way to go following the plan and doing
this stuff all right iliana joins us in
hollywood florida ileana welcome to the
show
hi lindsay how are you we are doing
great how can we help
yes um
my husband and i retire
and
we have a house that we own twenty
thousand dollars
um we don't have uh much saving
um
we need to know if better to refinance
and have money from the house or a
ticket loan and pay off the house
because all our investment is in our
home
so how can i get that cash out i i don't
like the options you've laid out so far
what you're asking for is should i do a
cash out refinance so should i rob
equity from my house
and put myself deeper into debt or do i
take out another loan to pay this one
off so now i have another loan sitting
over here which means we're just moving
around the debt do you need money is
that the problem
yes so how much do you guys have in
savings
not much around six thousand dollars
what do you need money for huh
um we have retirement and we have plans
um to do a couple travels
do you have any money in retirement
no so you have zero in retirement and
you have six thousand dollars cash to
your name
right what did you already what did
y'all retire from
excuse me i didn't hear what's what was
your trade before you retired what did
y'all do for a living
oh okay um i work for the school system
and
my husband work in the building so do
you have a pension from the school
system that's still coming in
yes okay and does he have a retirement
account of any kind or he just when he
quits building then he's not getting any
more money
he has a retirement um just a retirement
uh page you know account
uh retirement i'm receiving retirement
and
also my pension
so what is your monthly income right now
in retirement since you're both not
working
um our own money income is around 34
100 3 400 a month is what you guys get
okay is that enough to live off of are
you guys surviving
yes we are okay and you're able to pay
the mortgage
yes
okay what caused you both to retire
medical conditions both of you
no my husband we make the decision to
retire and
uh once you reach the age and i i have
to retire by medical conditions okay
well he if he's able to work he may have
to go back to work if you guys want to
live this dream of being able to travel
because truthfully you didn't you didn't
plan for what your dreams were and so
right now you're wanting to travel the
world but you're broke
and so you may at some point go you know
what if we want to do this we're going
to have to sell the house and we're
going to have to rent and if we can make
that work with our pension that will
give us some money but i want you to
invest that money because you guys are
how old are you two
i'm 58 and my husband is 60
okay 58 and 63. i mean you guys 50 53 or
63. excuse me you say 63 he is yes okay
okay so you guys still have a lot of
life to live and you need money to be
able to do that and so if 3 400 is going
to cut it for you that's great but it
sounds like you're wanting to do a lot
more you want to travel you want to have
fun and so that means we've got to have
a different picture of what that life is
going to look like and please please
listen to me under no circumstances take
a cash
cash cash
do not put your house on the block for a
loan
especially if you aren't going back to
work because you will lose your home
do not do that if you want to downsize
and pay cash for another house that's
right that's the way to do it but right
now you guys do not need to go backwards
while you're in retirement with no
income bad plan thanks for the call this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying thousand dollars about two
years after that i got a remote job that
pays me a hundred and thirty thousand
dollars all thanks to what i learned at
bethel tech you could be next get
started today at betheltech.net
and get 1000 to twenty five hundred
dollars off of your tuition again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality george campbell
joined today by dr john delony open
phones this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five call us up we'll
talk about your life your money your
mental health
whatever you wanna talk about and
speaking of mental health john uh i've
been watching the news i've been on
social media lately and it's not going
well not going well for me and for
everyone everyone that's right one of
the reasons is this new word that's been
popping up the metaverse
oh and uh you just gave me hemorrhoids
live on air i didn't mean to do it john
don't blame me for that
but here's the thing snoop dogg launched
his own virtual world
and someone in snoop dogg's virtual
world that he built in the metaverse
through this platform called sandbox
someone paid to be his neighbor and they
paid hundreds of thousands of dollars
for the virtual real estate next to
snoop dogg in a virtual land
this hurts my brain
all
can we just all
okay i like cool stuff i do i like act
like i don't know what's going on i do i
like cool stuff i like shiny toys i
really do
can we all just stop for a second and
understand the platform that is the
metaverse which is this idea that
i am going to live
and buy things
and finance things like clothes and cars
and
window drapes and hand towels
in a world that does not exist
you want a stat that'll make it even
worse john january alone sales of
metaverse real estate topped 85 million
dollars
do you know how many homeless people
that could have fed
or a lot how many soup kitchens could
have filled up
that's it's clinical insanity if you ask
me that i'm buying real estate in a
place that doesn't exist
not to that's even different than buying
like swords in my video game or whatever
laserjet sure that helps me be more lazy
or something skins and fortnite or
whatever the kids do these days go for
it man it helps you be more formidable
and you're playing in your alternate
universe that's even different than this
this is we have too much fake money we
owe at 30 trillion dollars as a country
now we have too much fake money in the
system
and we don't know what to use and we
have not enough social capital to go
hang out with other humans and so now
instead of a softball league we are
buying fake homes in fake places and
here's what's interesting john this
falls into your lane because the cnbc
article uh says this is creating more
loneliness the metaverse could be a
serious problem for kids experts say and
it goes on to talk about how there's
plenty of money to be made in the
metaverse and psychologists and mental
health experts say the race to turn a
profit is taking attention away from a
crucial question will the metaverse be a
safe place especially for kids and teens
the answer isn't encouraging the answer
shocking 1
000
no
our bodies are not designed to sit for
12 hours a day and exist in another
place so you're saying the solution
isn't more disconnection
stop the presses everybody no
the the company says their internal
values are move fast build awesome
things and live in the future when every
single psychological marker suggests
that living in the future is anxiety
that's what it is
and you should instead live in the
present and move
also bad advice i don't even mind moving
fast if you're going somewhere
productive it's worth going right um
we're building the future of social
connection i will tell you right now
that anything built on
imaginary places will ultimately has a
long enough tail will fail right he
encouraged workers this is zuckerberg to
focus on long-term impact i will tell
you that the long-term impact of not
moving your body not co-regulating with
other human beings in the same physical
space
and buying things that don't exist in
places that don't exist
the long-term impact will be one thing
hurting children
hurting adults
increasing the loneliness and the
anxiety and the depression that is
already blanketing our culture we need
less imaginary places and more kick a
soccer ball around with your kids can i
tell you something i did last night sure
i got home late we were here late last
night um we do it having meetings and
shooting things and whatever um shooting
videos and
i got home late and i have a thing where
i go open the door to my kids rooms i
just say a quick prayer and i
just tell them good night that's like i
want to make sure they hear my voice
even though i know they're asleep
and my six-year-old daughter her her
light was on her room
and i opened her door and she was
reading a book which she that she does
to to self-suit as she wakes up
and i looked at her and she looked at me
and
got quiet for a second i said
i will destroy you in air hockey if you
want to bring it on right now and she
looked at me and kind of froze her brow
and grinned from ear to ear and she goes
it's on
and she got up i put her on my shoulders
i carried around to the basement where
i've got this junky air hockey table we
played five minutes five minutes was all
i put the game on for five minutes we
talked father daughter trash we played
we laughed she told me about something
that happened at school that i know that
otherwise never would have had
it took five minutes to connect with my
kid carried her back upstairs she was
almost asleep before we got up there
later down was able to kiss her good
night tell her that i loved her
woke up this morning there was no drama
this morning it was a good morning it's
that social
human to human connection and it sounds
so dramatic and so hard the world needs
more that not more
hey man uh
see it tell me what snoop says when his
imaginary snoopness comes out in moses
imaginary lawn with his imaginary
lawnmower
what where does what a time to be alive
my friend
and there's an interesting quote here i
think parents will be asking themselves
do i feel safe knowing that mark
zuckerberg is the guy in charge of
deciding who influences my children
that's a powerful quote well mark
zuckerberg and his uh
now calling his employees metamates
nope i'm gonna hard nope
you and me are now uh
metamates
nope nope that just felt bad coming off
the tongue yeah they should have uh
pitched that better in the marketing
meeting but john there's a lot of issues
here and there's a lot of things to be
that are yet to be remain unseen because
we just don't know what do they have a
230 billion dollar
drop in market value the company yeah
everybody seems to see it
but there's a few folks saying let's
carry on
folks
be with real people please please be
with real people good word
well let's go on to real things like
real people who have real questions and
that is katie in wilmington north
carolina real food and living real katie
do you live in a real house hey
do i live where in a real home
yeah i do that's so great welcome to
real world good to see you katie
thank you i'm gonna step out of the
metaverse now perfect um so
i was wondering
my boyfriend told me to call in
first of all but
i was going over something i'm thinking
about taking out a loan
to pay off some medical debt
and use my car as collateral
i'm i'm gonna hard nope that one too
just like i did on metamates yes i'll
i'll stick with the hard no
so how much medical debt figured it
would be
about um twelve thousand what happened
hon
um i was hospitalized for something i
didn't want to go into anymore i'm so
sorry
mental health emergency i'm so sorry for
mental health well okay
i'll tell you real quick katie why it's
a bad idea it's a real dangerous move
because your main mode of transportation
could get repossessed yes
because you tried to move this debt
around so there's nothing secure about
these secured loans that you're talking
about and so what i want you to do
is do the hard work of getting rid of
this debt the slow way and that's paying
for it that's working out a payment plan
negotiating the bill down if you can
working with the hospital or whatever
medical provider you had for that but
there's no there's no shortcuts when it
comes to getting out of debt
unfortunately and that's what this is
hey katie can i can i
i've walked alongside countless i can't
count how many folks who have had to be
spend some time in the hospital for
psychiatric challenges for all kind of
challenges
most of the people that i've met with
when they get the bill when they get out
have some sort of shame or embarrassment
they just want to put the whole thing
quote unquote behind them and move on
do not be ashamed you did a hard brave
thing going to get the help that you
needed i'm proud of you
you're you're this is a part of your
healing journey but like george said do
this the right way hold your head up
high go negotiate that bill with the
hospital and pay it off over time
do do it right you're worth it you're
worth it you follow the baby steps the
debt snowball and call us back when
you're debt-free and we are going to be
celebrating with you katie thanks so
much for the call this is the ramsay
show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
ramsay personality george campbell
joined today by my friend dr john
deloney and we are taking your calls
triple eight eight two five
five two two five
rafael joins us in tucson arizona rafael
welcome to the show
hi hi
hey how can we help today how are you
brother good uh good thank you thank you
for taking my call
um
um
i am going through a divorce
i'm sorry um
yeah thank you how long have you been
married
um 25 years oh gosh i'm so sorry man
hey yeah
yeah man that's that's heartbreaking how
far are you guys into the process
um this just started
like five months ago so no paper signed
or anything like that yet
no nothing
actually we are in a good terms okay
and uh but the thing is we have a small
child
uh and
we want to
um
i want to be still close to her
and we were thinking to
refinance our house and buy a land in
order to
build a house with a casita on it
and i was wondering if that's a good
idea so you want to buy land and build
property to where you both live on that
property
yeah but
my wife and my daughter is gonna now
they're gonna live in the main house and
i'm gonna live in small casita so i
yeah so what what's the impetus for this
divorce you sound like y'all are
working awfully close together and on
the same page for two people who say
after a quarter of a century we need to
separate
uh okay can you repeat the question
what's the nature of the divorce why are
y'all why do you feel it necessary to
split up
um
i i think uh
communication is the main thing um you
we have a lot of problems
for years and
we try to stay together and play
together and
i think that
[Music]
it's it's not possible anymore okay i
mean we tried everything
so when you
um when you make the decision
to get a divorce
you are taking a
romantic relationship a friendship a
co-parenting relationship and you are
choosing to intentionally turn it into a
transactional relationship this is now a
business deal
and i would tell you if you were unable
to communicate
in a way that keeps you safe that keeps
your relationship whole and you find it
necessary to divorce
after 25 years
that sharing property and living in a
back house
is a disastrous idea
what i think you're wrestling with right
now is you can't imagine your life
without seeing that baby girl every day
is that true
yes it's hard i i have a little baby
girl man i can't even wrap my head
around it
i was just telling this last segment i
was i went and got my daughter up last
night at eight o'clock so i could spend
five minutes with her right i can't i
can't wrap my head around that
that is a consequence of you and your
wife's divorce
what you're not thinking through down
the road is if you're
soon to be ex-wife bring somebody else
home
or when you meet somebody and start
dating again
um or when she has a big party and fill
in the blank it's just a recipe for
disaster please don't do this
okay
get yourself an apartment in the
neighborhood where you're close make
sure every agreement and disagreement is
written down this is a transaction now
and you're gonna need to protect
yourself in writing so that you have um
legal standing to see your daughter at
at the sa you know regular intervals and
all that stuff that you'll that will
happen in the courts
but if you're gonna make this hard
decision to say we are done
we cannot be in the same place anymore
it's worth dividing this house up then
you have to go through and divide the
house up
and i know that is i'm talking to you
forget the radio i'm talking to dad to
dad here
i can't think of a more gut-wrenching
decision than what you've made okay so
i'm not making a light of it
i've just been the other side of this
thing with too many couples over the
years
this is a year and three year and five
year and ten year decision here okay
so do not sell your house and buy a
piece of land and live in the pool house
don't do that okay
okay so um then just
uh um leaving an apartment and uh
that's it and
move on yeah i mean i guess yeah i mean
that's really the choice or y'all you
can as part of your divorce decree y'all
can sell the house and split the place
split the
whatever however y'all decide to do that
to break up your your um
your estate and she can buy a small
house you can buy a small house i mean
it can be whatever that that stuff's all
negotiable and you all figure that out
with your lawyers
or figure it out together and then go
down to the courthouse together and sign
a piece of paper
but y'all could choose to be civil and
be grown-ups about the separation which
would be fun which would be wonderful if
you could do that for both for y'all and
for your kid but yeah that's that's
that's my recommendation man um don't
don't live in the pool house yeah uh to
what john said rafael you don't want to
be splitting property taxes and your
name's on the same stuff as her i mean
this is now a business transaction and
that means we got to go our separate
ways and that's hard or that her name is
only on the d and she evicts you at some
point out of the pool
so avoid that live as close as you can
to your daughter but
you got to cut ties here thanks for the
call that breaks my heart brother we're
thinking about you man yeah
allison joins us next in columbus ohio
allison welcome to the show
hi hey how can we help today
hey i was just calling with a question
about a small business ownership my
husband has a small business and his is
a sole proprietorship
so he doesn't have any employees and any
time we have sat down and tried to do
budget together to work through the
debts that we do have he um we've always
found it kind of difficult because of
the business you don't always have a set
amount of income if you have a piece of
equipment down or an unexpected
emergency so
when we go to do that we've always
wondered specifically my first part of
the question is do i separate the
business side from the personal side
since it is really all within our family
when we go to set up a budget and have
two different parts or do i keep it in
one part and also as far as emergency
funds go do we keep that one thousand
dollar emergency fund or do we maybe
make it a little business bigger to
account for his business team how much
debt do you guys have
uh well we have different kinds
he owns two large pieces of equipment
and we have debt on one of them probably
about in the amount of 16 or 17 000 i
would say okay we also have a personal
car loan and that's
about thirteen five hundred thirteen
thousand five hundred i would say and
then we have some consumer debt so we
have some on credit cards both a
business and some personal ones and
that's probably between eighteen to
twenty thousand all right so if i'm you
guys here's how this works all of that
business debt he signed for therefore
it's your personal debt so in that
regard you're going to put all of this
in the debt snowball together and attack
at smallest to largest regardless of the
interest rate
now on the bank account side we need to
have separate finances for what's going
on in the business please get separate
accounts
now i'm not saying that
yeah now his income that's going to be
part of the budget but the business
expenses transactions we need to keep
that separate so it doesn't get too
muddy
okay he needs to pay himself a salary
out of the business not just
dump it all into the checking account
you know what i mean okay
yeah how long has he had this business
we moved
um he's had it for maybe going on two
and a half years now he um has semi
trucks
do you all move money back and forth
yeah he gets paid by the company he has
a lease agreement with his business
account and then we move money each week
according to our needs to our personal
account yeah see that's that's a recipe
for disaster uh make sure you've got a
budget that says this is how much we're
gonna take out it's too easy to look at
that as some kind of as a credit or
credit card basically is what that's
going to look like and you're going to
end up bankrupting your business doing
that
okay and once this debt is paid off i
want him to run this business completely
debt-free which means if he's going to
get a piece of equipment we're going to
cash flow we're going to save up for it
hang on i'm going to have austin pick up
he's going to send you a copy of entre
leadership this is dave's book 20 30
years in the trenches of building a
business from a card table in his living
room to now multi hundreds of millions
of dollars and he did it all that's
right debt free with cash and he can too
this puts this hour of the ramsey show
in the books our thanks to james child
ben hill austin selby the whole crew in
there keeping the show afloat and you
america we appreciate you tuning in
we'll be back with you before you know
it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john delonie co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600-plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free
shipping with blinds.com there's no need
to renovate your entire home just change
out what's on your windows with upscale
choices like faux wood blinds cellular
and roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the ramsey
show i'm ramsey personality george
campbell joined today by ramsey
personality and best-selling author dr
john deloney now john all the all the
rage among the youth and among this
company is about your
new book and i just got the advanced
readers copy and i it was like christmas
morning yeah it was pretty intense i
didn't even know the advanced readers
copies were out down there yeah so they
whipped the
big sheet off of them and the feeding
functions very special usually only
high-profile folks in the media are high
profile but i'm
very excited to listen to it and i also
can't wait for the audiobook so you can
be piped into my ears while i look at
the words
so i'm excited you spent a lot of time
some would say too much time pouring
into this you've really poured your life
into it this is not a book that was just
in the last six months this is decades
and decades of foundation that you've
built so i just want you to talk about
what is going on with this book what are
you hoping people get out of it i'm
hoping people um
who are having trouble
sleeping they wake up at 2 a.m their
eyes just pop open and they're up for
the rest of night and that happens night
after night those who
find themselves raged at an elementary
school
a soccer game right or a little league
game
the moms who or dads who walk by the
mirror and just disgusted by what they
see or those who like i just i'm not
gonna ask for that promotion or they
don't get the promotion and they're like
i quit i'm at it
we're all carrying around these stories
and these bricks of just junk that has
haunted us for years and years stuff
that happened yesterday stuff that
happened 20 years ago and it has a
physiological conte like uh context man
that's consequences that man the stuff
that we were told stuff we were born
into
what church we went to we were kids
frames how we see god right or the stuff
our parents told us our coaches told us
frame how we interact with the world
and
this isn't a talk at you book but it's
my own story too because i've lived this
right and it's me walking alongside
folks think think dave
total money makeover right like he
was bankrupt and then here's his journey
back um and and very similar story with
me except it wasn't financial bankruptcy
it was me falling apart sitting in the
mud one night saying i need i need to do
something different so um it's the
journey about what's going on in our
culture in our world and why we feel
like this and most importantly what we
can do about it i'm pretty excited about
it yeah i'm really pumped it's called
own your past change your future and it
is on pre-sale right now and what i love
about pre-sale is we throw a bunch of
goodies at you to incentivize you so you
get the audio book you get the ebook and
it's crazy what our friends at
betterhelp did they said hey we want to
give everyone a month of free therapy if
they pre-order this book it because you
might need it after reading well it's
it's it's when you wake up on um you
know december 31st you're like tomorrow
i start my weightlifting journey and you
go downstairs and you don't have any
weights right and all you have in your
refrigerator is ice cream and and you
know the same old junk i didn't want
people to close this book and say
i'm starting right now and then they
call a local counselor or a marriage
counselor and then or a therapist of
some sort and they get on a six-month
waiting list and man our friends at
better help really they really stepped
up to the plate and hit it out of the
park and so they said man we will be
willing to we believe in this book so
much we'll ride alongside you and give
folks who listen a free month
um that's a significant
give on their part um just so people can
close this book and say it's time let's
get going and so i'm excited this is the
next step here absolutely
yeah that's right it takes working with
approach i'm excited to do it the right
way well i'm pumped for you for
everybody hey for everybody who's bought
this like the the pre-sales
it's kind of blowing all of our minds
here um i think we all were excited
about the book and i believe in it i'm
real i think it's a great book
the sales have been bonkers and i'm
really like from the bottom of my heart
is touching and so i'm grateful to all
the ramsey folks um i'm grateful that
y'all have reached out and bought this
book like you have and um please
continue to pick it up at pre-sale it's
fantastic well thanks for all the heart
and wisdom that you put into it i'm
really excited about it it's called own
your past change your future it's 20
bucks and you get way more value than
that so go get your copy ramsay
solutions.com is the place to do that
ryan joins us up next he's in grand
rapids michigan ryan welcome to the
ramsay show
hey guys how's it going hey great how
are you
doing well how can we help today
i have a question about a mortgage so my
wife and i are almost done paying off
student loan debts we've got about nine
thousand dollars left how far you've
gone with that will be how far has your
journey been uh we
uh we started with uh i think about 120
000. wow
dude you're a hero man keep going you're
almost there it's incredible yeah we've
been we've been really grinding it out
and that's kind of my question so we're
looking to buy a house um
once we finish paying off this debt and
i kind of toyed around the idea of
saying saving up to pay cash for it and
i'm just kind of wondering how realistic
realistic that might be and i feel like
kind of the motivating factor behind
this would be i feel like we've
worked so hard he added that i don't
want to go back into that again you know
this being a better
um
return i guess as a home versus student
loan
um but i feel like we just got out of
that i want to go right back into it i
just kind of want to hear you guys
opinion on that sure well first of all
it's an amazing and noble goal to even
want to save up and pay cash for a home
but let me also tell you there's no
shame in taking out a mortgage and
getting a home and doing it you know the
ramsey way under the right parameters so
this thing is a blessing and not a curse
on your family so it all comes down to
how long is this going to take what's
your income what kind of house are we
talking how much is it so walk me
through some of those numbers
right so we make about uh it varies a
little bit because i'm commissioned but
we make about 150 a year
um right now
um probably looking for a house
you know we don't need anything crazy we
do have one kid on the way right now our
first child so um that's kind of a
emoting factor as well but i'd probably
say you know something between
maybe the 150 200 000 range and that's
realistic for the grand rapids area
to get something that would be great for
you guys
yeah that'd be great for us you know
something you know
two three bedrooms
one bathroom one and a half somewhere
around there a little bit of land you
know we don't need anything crazy um we
don't don't actually know it will be in
it forever so uh it doesn't have to be
the end all be all for us but kind of
that's the plan right now
cool so how fast could you save up 150
grand once you're debt free and you have
a fully funded emergency fund of three
to six months of expenses
right so right now we live off of just
my wife's salary since she's salaried
and i'm commissioned um and we live on
probably
maybe around like 36 000 years she makes
uh
about 70. i make about 80 or 90.
so i don't know after that how much we'd
be able to save up but i think
we saved up over the past
uh
a little less than a year about 60 grand
that we put down on the student loans
yeah um
so i think it could be a two two and a
half year process saving up man that's
awesome i mean on that timeline if
that's what your goal is i'm not going
to dissuade you against that uh and at
the end of the two and a half years if
home prices went up a little bit and you
guys have the money and you're ready to
make that jump and you go all right
we're going to take out a small mortgage
in order to do this we're going to pay
it off really fast there's no shame in
that either so there's no there's no
wrong way to do this other than taking
out a mortgage that is way too big
relative to your income and that's very
clear you guys are not wanting to even
step into that territory and ryan i'll
tell you this um my student loan
situation my wife and i have seven
degrees between us is that right yeah we
have a lot
um
yeah one two three four great five
graduate degree we have a lot too many
we ended up at about where you were in
student loan debt
and i had that exact same feeling the
last thing on earth i'm gonna do after
we just almost killed ourselves getting
that thing paid off was to turn around
and dump it into another thing and
here's what it was it became less about
the debt and more about safety
i felt unsafe with that kind of debt and
that's very similar to you had a little
kid on the way all that very similar
journey
here's what helped me with that
is
taking out a big enough down payment
getting in so that i could get out of
that house if i needed to right and and
i'm kind of a mini prepper george and i
was talking about that off air there was
it's it's about the safety and so being
able to save up get that fully funded
emergency fund get a big enough down
payment that you can get into that house
and you can breathe
and i have found it personally i don't
like the debt i'm treating it as though
it is credit card debt we're paying it
off as fast as we can
but i also am really really glad that i
got my own place right now okay so i've
been down that road
do it the right way save up enough money
of a down payment save up a fully funded
emergency fund all the way to the top of
that six months and you're gonna find
yourself able to breathe and man maybe
it's a year that you put 80 you're 80
000 bucks in an account save it all up
and then go ahead and get that house and
then you've got a year or two on your
mortgage left and then knock it out if
you can do it under two years because i
don't want you to wait to invest for
years and years and years but if you're
saying we can do this in under two years
man that's incredible and then you can
invest all the income you want man
that's way to go dude you're crushing it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
dalone and on the debt-free stage in the
lobby of ramsey solutions it's keith and
courtney how you guys doing doing great
good guys we met earlier you didn't tell
me you're from lubbock
yeah they don't want to tease it they
don't want any crazies like you wow
it's good to see somebody from the 806
out here
all the way to do a dead free scream yes
all the way
it was a drive
oh you did the drive made that drive
flights were canceled we had no other
option and you still made it for the
dead free scream nothing was going to
stop you guys no way that's the kind of
resilience that made them dead free in
the first big truck
no
a little nissan yeah yeah already
bucking the trend man
very lunging that could all right so how
much debt did you guys pay off 90 000
891 and 26 cents wow not that we're
counting every penny yeah you've
memorized that okay how long did this
take 14 months
awesome oh you guys got after it what
was the range of income during this time
a little over a hundred to 140. wow
was this a raise did someone get a job
what happened here uh no there was a
pandemic
and i work in healthcare so worked a lot
we both donated plasma
anything that we could to
to get our income up wow so what do you
guys do for a living i'm a pharmacy tech
at a hospital i work in chemo wow and i
drive for pepsi delivery awesome
fantastic okay so what type of debt was
the 90 891 and 26 cents
a little bit of everything a couple of
credit cards uh furniture we paid off
three vehicles
we had a 25 000
personal loan that we had taken out to
get us out of debt completely wait that
doesn't work yeah i thought it was
surprising right life pack yeah i'll
take out this debt to pay off that
some reason it didn't work for us yeah
um one of those vehicles we paid off was
actually a fleece vehicle so we
got rid of that um
and there was a disney trip in there oh
finance on a credit card no how'd you do
it well a little bit of both okay yeah
so we had booked it actually before we
started our process so
um
i actually had two credit cards that
were already in collections and i had
been to court and everything on them so
that seems like a good time to then go
you know we should do we should go to
disney it sounds right you know
bad decisions were made but now we're on
a better track so who had the
conversation with who that said
this is a mess it was me actually yeah
um so like i said the pandemic
i work for a county hospital and
originally in the beginning they cut our
hours
and i freaked out because in the in the
beginning it was a lot slower
so they cut my hours and
i panicked i thought how are we going to
do we are living paycheck to paycheck
now there's no way we're going to be
able to do this on less hours
um and now we're making six figures in
lubbock which goes a lot further than
like in nashville and you're still
paycheck to paycheck yeah right yeah we
were we were stupid i mean
too much eating out yeah
so
in august of 2020
everything had started to open up again
and we looked at our spending
and eating out was the first thing that
kind of caught my attention we were
starting to eat out a lot
and it was eating up so much of our
budget and so i asked keith i was like
why don't we challenge each other to not
eat out at all the month of september
wow
and just thinking of that thinking how
much that was going to save us
and then over that month of september we
made it through the month of september
but over that month i started
researching
how to get outside of debt that we made
too much money to be this poor there was
no reason for that at all
um
and i had a cousin that had actually
followed dave ramsey and they were
debt-free but i hadn't she talked about
it but i hadn't really listened to her
much
so thankfully he follows me in anything
that i i want which is good and bad
texas husband right there
so i um i approached him about hey let's
let's start this and see what we can do
and we hit gazelle from day one so
october 1st of 2020
is when we we started there was a lot of
ramen noodles and
pb j sandwiches and like i said that's
right yeah wow can i ask you this um
i hear families that make a concerted
effort like y'all did let's stop eating
out
start making food at home
that it has it has a centrifugal force
that
we're all in the kitchen cooking
together which means we're talking a
little bit more we're laughing a little
bit more and even husband picks up the
dishes every once in a while and the
kids are around like it has this
leavening effect that raises the whole
family up right is that you all
experience something similar oh yeah yes
we have become so much closer in all of
this that's awesome road trips we always
listen to the podcast our eight-year-old
is
comes on and he's like oh dave again but
he listens and he knows the music he
knows the sound he every death scream
every scream he does it along logan we
feel your pain little man we feel your
pain he's like mom you're outing me on
national radio oh we listen to dave's
voice and the saxophones too he's the
reason we're here he wanted to do this
cool he's he's been practicing he's
ready morris caught them taught and that
little guy he saw you guys hustle and
bust your butt to get out of this debt
so that you could change your family
tree yeah and i i want to mention keith
actually got hurt at work back over the
summer and hasn't worked since october
21st
he has been on workmen's comp so we've
we finished out our last two months
of on on whitman compa of just busting
and doing whatever we need to do to make
it happen we
changed insurance companies anything
that we could do to save save money and
saved ourselves
wow saved our family in the process you
guys are heroes thank you so much for
coming all this way so we can celebrate
with you so what do you tell another
couple out there what's the key to
getting out of debt
uh working together if you don't work
together you're never gonna succeed
yeah there was lots of
compromise on both of our behalfs but we
would sit down and and do our budget
together and i'm a little obsessive i
carry my laptop everywhere with me and
if it goes the slightest bit off we're
adjusting that spreadsheet
and
but we do it together and it's it's made
our family stronger because we do it my
way on my laptop but we do it together
that's right yes
it's like he knows us he doesn't get to
touch the laptop but he gets to look on
my
i love it i love it so did you guys have
any cheerleaders anyone think you're
crazy along the way
lots of both
keith's parents have been awesome they
support us they actually started their
own journey and they paid off a lot as
well and became like jet-free also like
i said my cousin
elisha was a strong supporter
co-workers they all thought i was crazy
working so much i was working anywhere
from 70 to 80 hours a week some weeks
and going down the street and selling
blood on the way home right you do what
you got to do good we got ourselves in
that hole we had to get ourselves out i
love that attitude i love it taking
responsibility and it got you here and
now you're making 140 000 and you get to
keep every penny after uncle sam gets
this cut exactly that's the way to do it
and we're less than 50 on our house so
wow we'll see you soon right we'll see
you in a few more months come back
fantastic that's awesome okay so you
brought logan with you yes elisha
couldn't make it today okay he's 22 had
to stay home and work you know he's got
bills too so oh i get it well bring him
up here how old's logan logan is eight
eight and clearly has been practicing
this guy knows this stuff better than me
he can do the show probably oh yeah and
if you want to know what a west texas
uniform looks like logan and dad are
wearing it
he wanted to wear the cowboy hat too so
when in rome brother hey you look great
i love it well let's get to it you guys
have worked so hard to get to this point
and it's come down to the final moments
we've got a copy of baby steps
millionaires for you it's dave's
best-selling book and it's the next
chapter for you guys as you build wealth
and give generously and we're going to
give you a copy of the total money
makeover so you can get someone else's
journey started and get them gazelle
intense all right here we go keith and
courtney and eight-year-old logan
91 000 paid off in 14 months making 100
to 140
let's hear a debt-free screen count it
down
three
two one
oh that is that's what it's all about
right there
it started with him going mom turn this
off and it turned into him being on this
stage screaming at the top of his little
lungs about debt freedom
man
that kid is never gonna know debt i'll
tell you that much john exactly right a
legacy left a family tree changed it's
so worth it adversity crisis they
overcame it all keith and courtney and
logan can do it and you can to america
you could be on this stage we'd love to
see it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
george campbell joined today by dr john
delony our scripture of the day comes
from proverbs 19 21.
many plans are in a man's heart but the
council of the lord will stand
john lennon said life is what happens
when you're busy making other plans
which is a great circle back to
living in the future in the metaverse no
that's right live now life is what
happens when you are living in a virtual
reality with fake friends
in imaginary curtains classic john
lennon quote classic john lennon i love
it let's go to the phones this hour dee
joins us in washington d.c dee welcome
to the show
thank you how are you doing great how
can we help
so i
make about sixty thousand dollars a year
i have about eighteen and savings um
another eighth in retirement um but i
have seventy five thousand in student
loans and you know
yeah i would really love to buy a home
in the next three years and i
you know i would love some financial
guidance here most of what i've learned
about managing my money has come from
just my
like lessons and hits i've taken and
googling things so
yeah the school of hard knocks and
google both great teachers yeah yeah hey
so where'd you get connected with our
crazy crew
so i actually just stumbled across you
guys by accident on youtube
nice our youtube guys love to hear that
yeah well i'm glad you found us we're
gonna we're gonna walk alongside you
here and get this whole ship turned
around for you okay yes so i love that
you've got these goals to get a home
and that will come one day but right now
we've got a mess to clean up with these
student loans and so you've got some
retirement going which tells me you're
investing right now correct
that's right how much are you investing
every month
um so coming out of my paycheck baby
oh sorry i think we we lost you there
for a second d you still with us oh yes
okay we're hearing some static
oh sorry about that sorry
um i would say about 200 a month 200 a
month
okay and are you getting like a tax
refund
or do you owe
um i do get a tax refund um when i sell
my taxes each year but my contributions
are on the raw spaces so they're all um
after tax okay how much of a refund do
you get
um this year not that much about 250.
okay okay all right i'm just trying to
figure out where we can find some money
here for you uh so our plan is it's
counter cultural it's different it
doesn't make sense on paper but it works
every time you work it and so basically
every time dee here's where we start
which you already have this is a great
problem to have you have 18 dollars in
savings baby step one the very first
step is to obviously we're gonna make a
budget so that's separate but baby step
one we want a thousand dollars put away
in a savings account so you have that
but you also have 17 000 after that
don't you
and so baby step two is where we move on
to the debt snowball so we're going to
list out all of your debts every student
loan if that's your is that all of your
debt is the 75
uh basically i have 700 in credit card
but that's it okay so that would
probably go to the top of what we call
the debt snowball where you list them
all from smallest to largest we're
ignoring interest rate because this
isn't about math this is about behavior
change and progress and motivation and
we're going to start attacking that
little one with a vengeance while making
minimum payments on the rest
and so if you list them out instead of
looking like a 75 000 mountain now it
becomes oh i can see the 700 bucks i can
knock that out and then i've got a 2 000
loan i'm going to knock that out so you
begin to feel the progress you free up a
payment you can put that on to the next
debt and the next debt and the snowball
starts to roll does that make sense
yeah so by tomorrow
you only owe 58 000 that feels pretty
good doesn't it because you applied the
17 that you already have in savings you
just knocked out small debt small debt
small debt bigger debt medium-sized debt
medium-sized debt and now you're on your
way
see what we just did there
yeah and you should feel terrified
because now you're going i have a
thousand dollars to my name what are
they trying to tell me to do they're
completely exposed you are scared and
that's the whole point here it's gazelle
intensity probably here to say that you
are sprinting for your life you're gonna
take an extra shift you're gonna get up
early and deliver papers and that's
something we did in the 1800s before
george was born that's right but you're
going to
run run run for the next six months six
to 12 months and you're gonna knock this
thing out and the other thing dee that i
would tell you to do is to pause
investing and again that's going to hurt
a little bit right because you're not
going to see those investments grow
remember this is temporary and we want
you to feel the fire under your tail to
get rid of this debt so you can get back
to investing and guess what when you get
back to investing you're not going to be
investing 200 a month you're going to be
investing 15 of your household income
which is way more than that so you're
going to make up for it on the back end
but once you get rid of all this
consumer debt using the debt snowball
you're going to be in baby step 3 which
is where you get to some financial peace
you're going to build that emergency
fund from 1 000 up to three to six
months of expenses
and then we're going to invest 15 of our
household income into retirement if
you've got kids we're going to put away
some for college we're going to begin to
pay off the house but you mentioned you
want to buy a house and so the step that
would fall into is what we call baby
step 3 b so once you have the fully
funded emergency fund man now we have
all of our income back at our disposal
that's our greatest wealth building tool
and you can begin to save up a down
payment i want you to save up 10 to 20
percent
and do a 15 year fixed rate mortgage
with a payment that's no more than a
quarter of your take-home pay
do you feel the progress already i'm
excited for you
i'm terrified actually
hey dee what do you do for a living
uh i work for the government we're okay
is there opportunities i know some
government jobs are 24 7 365 are there
opportunities for you to go work a shift
or deliver ubereats in the evenings
to work on saturday's tour
okay
i need you to hear us very clearly this
is going to be hard and you're going to
be tired
and anybody selling you anything other
than exhaustion and fatigue and grinding
it out is lying to you and trying to
take your money
okay this is hard and everyone around
you will say you make 60 grand what are
you doing what do you mean you can't go
out to eat what do you mean you're
bringing your lunch over to our house
why are you being a weirdo
because i want to sleep at night i don't
want to wake up at 2 am and i can't
breathe i don't want to see every
government headline come out and i look
at my account and say if i get
furloughed i i'm gonna default on right
you see what i'm saying
as a guy who just paid his house off
george
his entire cadence is lighter he just
walks through the world a little bit
lighter because he owes nobody anything
i'm a dangerous man with some money in
my pocket i i you probably the least
dangerous guy i know george bush
john
okay
dee do you hear what i'm saying
i hear you so here's what here's what
we're going to do i'm going to give you
once you hang on the line and we're
going to give you a year of our flagship
product okay ramsey plus it's got the
the full fledged app the every dollar
app it's going to help you track all of
your expenses it's going to have all of
the fpu classes taught by dave and me
and george and others in the product and
it's going to give you a it's going to
have all of the stuff in it it's going
to walk with you along and invite your
friends over to watch it with you man
you get a small little gang of you all
do this together because it's going to
be counter culture it's going to be
weird but this is a this is the big time
product and i'm gonna send it to you for
free but you gotta promise that you'll
use it over the next years is that is
that a deal
that's a deal all right i'm proud of him
so glad you're in our gang trust the
process trust the process and you're
gonna change everything hang on the line
here dee there's so many people out
there who are just as terrified as you
and when you get around them and you
guys start to share your wins and share
what's working and you get excited it
changes everything i'm more terrified
about you sitting there with student
loans for the next 20 years 35 000
and then you get a huge mortgage that
you barely can afford you're not
sleeping at night you've got 17 lenders
to pay you're living off of credit cards
that's a much more terrifying reality
then
one or two years of sacrifice and we're
going to start working on this house and
we just need to adjust our expectations
give yourself a different picture of
what the future looks like and the bad
news is it's going to be longer than you
think
the good news is it's going to be so
much better than you could have ever
imagined when you get there that's a
that's an interesting interesting thing
to to remember it's going to it's going
to be harder than you think
and it's going to feel
10x better than you think it's going to
when you get there it's worth it every
time you can ask anyone who's been on
our debt-free stage they'll tell you i
would i would do it all over again yeah
this is worth it they glow they glow
they glow so good you're gonna get there
dee we're proud of you cheering you on
that puts this hour of the ramsay show
in the books my thanks to my awesome
co-host dr john doloni all the booth
folk who keep the show afloat and
running smoothly thanks to you and you
america my good friend thank you thank
you for saying that our friendship
youtube has been worried about if me and
john are on the fritz we're doing great
we're doing great
all right hey remember folks spend
wisely save intentionally give
generously that's what it's all about
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you